mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
jede minute wird wald zerstört eine
fläche von 27 fußballfeldern
die klimaerwärmung schreitet voran der
co2 ausstoß ist gigantisch
[Applaus]
während am weltklimagipfel in glasgow
politikerinnen und politiker um einigung
ringen engagieren sich kultur und
kunstschaffende auf ihre weise fürs
klima
was können sie bewirken
wie können wir alle etwas bewegen
antworten bei kulturplatz
[Musik]
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ja wir
machen heute station im aargauischen
hecklingen und besuchen ein junges paar
das sich einsatz für klimaziele und
nachhaltigkeit soeben wurden sie mit
ihrem neubau ausgezeichnet bei der
verleihung des schweizer solarpreises
[Musik]
während außer die welt zur un
klimakonferenz nach glas geschaut nehmen
wir sie mit auf hausbesuchen zudem
zeigen wir ihnen auch was die kunst
bewirken kann in der klimadebatte
konsumiert
[Musik]
ja dann liegt damit auch jetzt gerne mal
und zwar wie miriam und mario
rossi ist er doch war
besuchen das energiekonzept
es sind nämlich
in europa oder in energie es kenntnis
gesetzt eine durch die ersten blick
verständlich vor ihnen das dass er so
eine außergewöhnlich fußes mario
klitschko ist ganz kurz erklären warum
das auch jetzt seine tochter könnte das
ist meines ein holzbau und meint sarah
lark vor vielleicht integriert wo man
sowohl das was wir nach gemüse
sind mit sorge und also wenn man es
zusammen bilanzkennzahlen
produzieren knapp für jeden mal so viel
energie wie das mir jetzt brauchen wir
noch detailliert darüber dass
mobilität aus wenn damals elektroauto
und wenn wir jetzt das auto würde die
bilanz erreicht und dann produzieren wir
doppelt so viel energie wert dass man
hat also fürs haushaltsstrom und mit dem
rettungswagen wurde durch claire und der
schweiz das hat auch viel holtriem hus
ist ein alter baustoffe aber auch
zukunftsweisend gibt es eine andere
materie wo in zukunft können ich denke
ja es gibt
sie weil es hat ein bisschen co2 diente
es gibt aber eine überlegung dass man
auf andere werke co2 aus der luft nimmt
und ich verfolge bachstadt zum beispiel
dann kann verbauen und so widersprechen
sie interessant da für arbeit in
ghettos untermain zum beispiel oder gar
nicht ran besonders mit der garantie
machen zukunftsmusik aber
der weltklimakonferenz in glasgow haben
letzte woche 100 staaten einen pakt
geschlossen
das ziel der wald soll gerettet werden
die traurige realität ist hingegen eher
wird täglich kleiner durch abholzung
durch brandrodung ganz besonders im
amazonasgebiet
der amazonas größter regenwald der welt
artenreichste ort der erde die
klimaanlage unseres planeten
aufs bild gebannt vom preisgekrönten
brasilianischen fotografen victoria
letzte handgriffe für seine ausstellung
in der brasilianer stiftung basel im
rahmen des kulturfestivals culturescapes
vor wenigen tagen weilte er noch im
regenwald war einmal mehr augenzeuge der
ungeheuerlichen vorgänge
marianas bilder eine dokumentation der
vernichtung amazoniens
[Musik]
es ist furchtbar mit anzusehen wie alles
zerstört werden auf der anderen seite zu
sehen wie die menschen dort mit der
umwelt 1 sind im rhythmus der natur
leben der tiere flüsse und des wetters
das ist wunderschön
[Musik]
dieses leben ist in gefahr
seit 50 millionen jahren existierte
amazonas die lunge der welt
[Musik]
die wirtschaftliche ausbeutung begann
vor gerade einmal 50 jahren jetzt haben
abholzung und brandrodung ein
historisches ausmaß erreicht die
konsequenzen fatal
die tropische vegetation speichert
unmengen an co2 sterben die bäume wird
das treibhausgas freigesetzt das
erdklima heizt sich auf
die hamas bilder halten die katastrophe
fest in großaufnahme
auf diese arbeit ist meine mission ich
folge meinem instinkt und er führt mich
immer wieder wird
ich spreche mit der bevölkerung versuche
zu verstehen
möchte der welt andere perspektiven
aufzeigen sichtbar machen was im
amazonas vor sich geht
das betrifft ja nicht nur mein land
sondern die ganze welt
weil der klimawandel alle betrifft aber
auch weil die ganze welt sich am
amazonas bedient
rodungen für palmöl etwa haben sich in
brasiliens regenwald im vergangenen
jahrzehnt verdreifacht
das öl landet in unseren supermärkten
verarbeitet in lebens- und
reinigungsmitteln oder in
körperpflegeprodukten die wimperntusche
krems lippen tomaten
wir treffen annina berri von bruno
manser fonds in der masoala halle im
zürcher zoo
die sozial anthropologin hat zum thema
mensch und umwelt beziehungen doktoriert
die unkontrollierte zerstörung des
regenwaldes soll bis 2030 gestoppt
werden verspricht die
staatengemeinschaft an der
klimakonferenz von glasgow
aber er hält das für eine fast
so lang gebiete macht wie bisher dann
hat dann glaubt sich cavaliers er muss
jetzt kommt
eine weitere immense bedrohung für den
amazonas die goldgewinner hunderte
illegale goldminen fressen sich bis in
die hintersten ecken des regenwaldes und
brasiliens präsident porto nato will den
bergbau noch ausweiten per gesetz
[Musik]
die leute werden geradezu ermutigt
illegale geschäfte zu machen
wenn der präsident sorgt dass so viel
land für so wenige ureinwohner
und dann ist das wie ein aufruf dorthin
zu gehen und das land auszubeuten
gold ist begehrt der goldpreis steigt
seit jahren ob hinter all dem glanz ein
dreckiges geschäft steckt ist schmuck
nicht anzusehen annina aber lädt fordert
hier mehr transparenz
die schweiz könnte vorreiterin sein
praktikum
und ein bisschen als konsumentinnen und
konsumenten gar nicht wo das geld
herkommt und dann wäre es alles
die größten regenwald vernichter im
amazonas sind aber rinderzucht sowie
soja anbau zur fütterung der tiere die
wirtschaft ist für 80 prozent der
regenwaldzerstörung verantwortlich in
brasilien leben mehr rinder als menschen
über 200 millionen tiere die profit gier
nimmt keine rücksicht auf land und leute
es geht ums nackte überleben
[Musik]
dahinter stecken die größten fleisch
konzerne der welt sie brüstet sich damit
die ernährer der welt zu sein
ich sage nicht dass wir nun alle
vegetarier werden sollten aber wir
müssen uns bewusst sein
importiertes fleisch dass wir in europa
oder überall auf der welt kaufen fördert
die nachfrage und damit die
regenwaldzerstörung
der fleischkonsum steigt weltweit auch
in der schweiz das rind schnitzel können
wir uns immer noch viel zu oft
2020 wurde hierzulande so viel fleisch
konsumiert wie nie zuvor allein 300
tonnen rindfleisch importiert aus
brasilien
die ausstellung in der brasilianer
stimmten mit marias bildern mutet an wie
ein schaufenster in die vergangenheit
und in die zukunft
die vergangenheit
mächtige bäume und intakte
biodiversitäts die das klima der welt
regulieren
die zukunft was bleibt nach brandrodung
und ausbeutung totes land
[Musik]
wir haben noch nie ein solches ausmaß an
zerstörung gesehen wie jetzt
ich mache diese bilder um einen beitrag
zu leisten für die geschichtsschreibung
und für die gesellschaft damit die
menschen verstehen was hier passiert
ich muss weiter machen
der regenwald sprint
rauchzeichen die nicht mehr zu übersehen
sind
[Musik]
das wird es zurück fünfte kind
wenn man noch regen um rund um sport
[Musik]
dann würde sich auch weil die
begehbare
kleiderschrank ct und die
[Gelächter]
genau s200exr der bauherr vom autohaus
und konnten die haben wir locker machen
das ist das los angeles um dort
erscheint hier was machst du
dein büro wo nicht schaffen so einen die
beratungen für die industrieunternehmen
was das heißt ein helfer dienen zum
beispiel zum energiesparen oder
das ist ganz anders sieht der industrie
sondern hat die bewahrt der
hauseigentümer was von sieben auch
münsters saniert das wird sie heute
machen was willst du dass es auch egal
sein wie es mit dem gebäude kann die 2
[Musik]
willkommen
crushed ice ist das energiekonzept noch
kurz erläutern also wir
mit solarenergie photovoltaik der
situation der quadratmeter wo man daher
das motto kraus ausnutzten
in kombination mit der wärmepumpe ist
noch ein speziell das mit einem
sondertarif
verbohrter luftteilchen nutzer zum die
wand gespielt und ich hatte am handy
unter einem modul die zweite luft und
machen eine die jungs trugen zu der
wärmepumpe und die verbraucher dass die
effizienter läuft und er ist
[Gelächter]
ja genau das ist der clou
schnellschuss aktion
ökologisch weil über wellness und eine
chronologie und tony abbott den bauhof
geburtstage seiner oper und der platz
der andere wirklich liebe
auch viele kunstschaffende engagieren
sich vehement für die klimadebatte wenn
auch mit komplett anderen mitteln seit
knapp 40 jahren existiert diese bewegung
und sie wird zum glück immer stärker ein
rot leuchtendes mahnmal für all das grün
auf der welt von der autobahn in glasgow
auszusehen soll die installation der
künstlerin mary ellen carroll zum
nachdenken anregen
rund um den weltklimagipfel gibt es
derzeit viel kunst zu sehen höchste zeit
zu handeln sagen diese werke
der deutschen künstler art drossel
verbindet seine performance in
schottland gar mit einem appell via
instagram
[Musik]
zweifellos engagiert aber die frage sei
gestattet nicht auch ein bisschen
blauäugig ob man mit kunst die welt
retten kann darüber streiten auch die
experten der soziologe harald welzer
jedenfalls glaubt nicht daran viel zu
hoch gegriffen meint ihr diese pseudo
aufklärerische anspruch der damit
verbundenen es am besten immer noch mit
einer moralischen codierung ist das
gegenteil von dem wie ich eine
politisierung von themen erzeuge das ist
einfach dass das falsche mittel und das
ist auch so eine sonne
selbstüberschätzung derjenigen die so
eine form von kunst machen
ist das so schaut man die werke des
schweizer künstlers julia scharri er an
der sich mit natur klima und
schmelzenden eisbergen befasst berührt
dass viele emotionalen sitzt das etwas
in bewegung
seit jeher fokussieren künstler auf die
natur die ausstellung als beats im
kunsthaus zürich zeigt wie sich diese
auseinandersetzung wandelte
von den idyllischen natur malerei
über die initiative kunst bis hin zu
werken die die industrielle
vereinnahmung der natur anklagen
ist die kunst eine art moralischer
kompass philipp kunst wie
ästhetische erlebnisse schaffen und
erlebnisse sind nicht moralisch ist ein
weiteres sogar ausgesprochen unmoralisch
was wichtig ist hier ist ja ein
ästhetisches erlebnis mit den menschen
konfrontiert werden aber die
gleichzeitig auch durch diese wortlose
konfrontation mit einer realität in
diesem fall schmelzendem eis
menschen natürlich auch ein bisschen in
die pflicht nimmt und ihre
vorstellungskraft beflügelt und ihn
vielleicht gefühle und gedanken
einpflanzen sie vorher noch nicht hatten
gerade der dänisch isländische künstler
olafur eliasson steht für starke bilder
2003 ließ er in der londoner tate modern
eine künstliche sonne aufgehen mit
seinem weather project näherte er sich
dem thema klima an und machte dies zu
seiner mission vor zwei jahren dies eher
eisblöcke schmelzen ein klar lesbarer
kommentare zur klimakatastrophe ist
einfach unglaublich wichtig dass wir
auch mit unseren körpern den welt und
das klima war die kehrseite eliasson
verbrauchte für den transport der
eisblöcke rund 35 tonnen co2 so viel wie
zehn flüge nach new york hin und zurück
heiligt der zweck die mittel
fragen wir elke buhr chefredaktorin des
kunstmagazins monopol
soll man überhaupt co2 verbrauchen um
kunstwerke zu machen die gegen den co2
verbrauch sind das hört sich auf den
ersten blick natürlich ziemlich abwegig
an auf der anderen seite sagen ja auch
viele die in der ökologie sehr engagiert
sind dass es wichtig ist dass die kunst
sich damit beschäftigt weil diese bilder
die dann entstehen die brauchen wir für
den bewusstseinswandel im namen des
klimas engagieren sich mehr und mehr
künstler aus allen sparten
wie schätzt viele so viele blumen die
kraft der kunst ein die erde zu retten
da war die tragödie etwas wo man eine
person trage scheitern sahen der welt
und das ist immer deswegen weil diese
person eigentlich einen charakter vieler
hat die heißt dass sie mit dieser welt
nicht dass sie dass sie nicht in die
ordnung passt deswegen müssen sie
scheitern dann wird die ordnung wieder
hergestellt und dann irgendwann um 1800
kommt schildern und der stellt figuren
auf die bühne die scheitern auch an den
verhältnissen und gehen auch tragisch
zugrunde aber sie sagen vorher noch ich
scheitere aber die ordnung ist falsch
auf einmal der gedanke dass wenn ich
scheitere an der welt das ist vielleicht
nicht der fehler mein fehler als armer
sünder sondern das ist ein fehler einer
korrupten ordnung das macht die ganz
neue denkräume auf und das kann kunst
erreichen wenn sie gut ist ja der
argentinische künstler tomás saraceno
macht solche den krone auf
er forscht seit jahren nach
möglichkeiten des fliegens ohne fossile
brennstoffe
auch tomas saraceno finde ich ganz
fantastisch wie er das in seine gesamte
praxis integriert also wie er zum
beispiel seine galerie dazu gebracht hat
seine ausstellung mit solarstrom zu
betreiben auch das kann man sagen ist ja
letztlich nur symbolisch aber wir
brauchen viele von diesen symbolen der
kunstbetrieb ist durch die klimadebatte
in bewegung geraten andreas greiner
beispielsweise errechnet für jedes
seiner werke den co2 verbrauch
kompliziert diesen mit baumpflanzungen
kalt ist klar an kunst jetzt die welt
ändern kann kunst die politischen
verhältnisse
verwandeln natürlich kann sie das nicht
aber sie kann glaube ich schon eine
wichtige stimme in einem prozess sein
der damit zusammenhängt dass wir ändern
wir über die welt denken die wir in der
welt selbst stehen wir werden
wahrscheinlich keine zeit zu geben sich
jede gesellschaft fragen muss was sie
bereit es aufzugeben und in diesem
konflikt hat kunst wirklich eine
existenzielle herausforderung für kunst
gegen den klimawandel kann nicht nur in
glasgow wirksame zeichen setzen gerade
jetzt brauchen wir die kunstschaffenden
damit sie uns inspirieren mahnen und
ermuntern uns als gesellschaft
weiterzuentwickeln
[Musik]
das treffen oder auch miriam rutscht und
zwar auf dem sofa da immer nachhaltiger
es mir ja die man hat ja das muss sich
muss
damit seine zusammenhocken und
entscheiden also er hat sehr viel die
inputs natürlich braucht immer mal gerne
kritisch und hudson fluss und den
zusammen was für kritische fragen hast
dann kann
[Gelächter]
ich setze mich natürlich weniger mit
dynatrace ernannt und dementsprechend
auch stars wie zürich stars lohnt sich
das ja eigentlich selbst ein
finanzielles ist es wildtiere
durch die investition schon mehr oder
wenn man nicht auf sondern hat der
photovoltaik anlage ab und man hätte den
sieg kosten sie sagen die überschlags
meister gibt riesige franken abzüglich
fördergelder der creme der hand ein
stromüberschuss von ihr produkt ihre und
gab danach wurde das heißt effizient
eigentlich mit der anlage könnte dennoch
wird der strom verkaufen zum einen
besser der preis werde dass man im netz
würden verkauft und sie profitieren
davon ist für sie günstiger werden
sieben von jetzt werden sie kompliziert
[Gelächter]
die luft hat dauernd technische gründe
behindert
es wird durch eine form luftfeuchtigkeit
7 grad im winter hat viel
luftfeuchtigkeit und hilft hat trotz der
krise das ist regulären das holz für die
kranke aufnahmen street und da wieder
abgibt und das immer schön reguliert was
von tieren auf mir aber nicht als
fachfrau wurde ab dass ich für dich will
ich habe bis ganz besonders dem haus ein
abstellen dass ich einfach kombination
mit dem holz er schätze und ich schön
finde das ganz anderes habe ich zum
beispiel schätzt dass ich mit
solarenergie
dusche oder auch ganz bewusst wenn ich
weiss
aussteller nutzen
im nächsten frühling als erste kind hat
das augenaufschlag geistig wirklich noch
so engagiert für nachhaltiges lama ja
ich glaube schon also ich bisher
inspirierte gibt immer wieder durch
mario und das war halt so bringt aber
natürlich wenn man überlegt was
eigentlich irrelevant durften ist es
umso wichtiger sich die gedanken zu
machen was haben wir eigentlich für das
konzept in sachen reise könnte
das möglichste flugreise verzichten so
gut wie scott ganz einfach irgendeinen
ort paar weitere reise machen und direkt
machen
bis 8
apropos reisen wenn sie wieder einmal
das schlechte gewissen plagt sei ihnen
gesagt es gibt lösungen in sachen reisen
und eine solche hat die 19-jährige yahoo
aktuell zu sehen bei uns auf kultur bei
instagram
man muss überhaupt nicht weiter sondern
man kann die ferne ganz neu entdecken
nämlich ob es in der schweiz das seit
zehn studenten und autorin vor dem buch
interessiert
das buch ist für mich eigentlich eine
inspirierende reiseführer für
klimabewussten und mini
in ihrem buch tut etwas ziemlich simples
das aber bestechend ist sie sucht und
findet landschaftliche parallelen
zwischen der schweiz und internationalen
preise destinationen
und der bedeutung idee dass man über das
visuell rechtlicher verpflichtung moment
hält der vision wir das gefühl oder was
sie da bewusst jetzt habe ich fang ist
so spricht wie
unglaublich mit die landschaft
die 19 jährige reiste für die
maturarbeit für das buch fotografieren
durch die schweiz und findet im nahen
das fremde sind reise alternativen mit
garantierter klima spanisch vor allem
aber spielerische denkanstöße
es ist einfach mehr in momentaufnahmen
und ich glaube dass moment
es komme auf die betrachtungsweise haben
nicht auf die flug neuen social hub nur
die große weite welt lockt immer fort
und nie mehr fliegen stellt nicht mehr
schwierig
[Applaus]
für die frauen wird alternative und
führt offenhält
bewusste reflektieren wenn so schnell
sind sagen okay jetzt ist er momentan
verzichten wir jetzt dazu cannstatt
flugzeugen in europa
einen wochenendtrip in new york machen
nachher den wochenendtrip
töten
mit dem schreiben des buches wird seelig
selbst zur nachhaltigkeit aktivistin
[Musik]
das fordert amerika aber dass man hier
mal da muss max kraft und gefühlt und
jetzt
mache das hätte mir ganz viel bewirkt
haben inspirieren
das buch soll zu klima schonen 34
zusammenführen zugleich ist eine
aufforderung das reisen an sich neu zu
denken und das ist dringend nötig
[Musik]
ja das war unser besuch in hecklingen
und nächste woche geht es bei uns weiter
mit hongkong wo unisex eine einzigartige
sammlung einem museum verschenkt gleich
jetzt geht ihr weiter mit der
sternstunde philosophie und donatella di
cesare eine gute woche für sie
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos